so this is more unstable build it's a
little bit later in development but it
does have our ship power crafting from
the shipyard
so before you would have seen the
default hull now this is a little bit
further on it's entirely code at our so
if it looks a little bit confusing at
times as because we haven't had any sort
of pass code for that sort of thing but
what it essentially is anyone familiar
with 3d modeling tools is you're able to
shape your hull with these sections to
basically anything that you want we have
these little controls here as well so
you can kind of create a more curved
sort of shape if you want you can pull
extra sections out you can even sort of
get a basic shape by just yeah and you
can also increase sections of it here
and then when you've got the basic shape
you can go in and start to kind of make
other adjustments show you what where
this bits off hang out here and curve it
in like that so pull that in and it's a
big thing like the players were sort of
asking for they really want to craft
their own ship we didn't want a sort of
just creating it by blocks which i think
is a lot of sort of solutions to it this
kind of player creativity we started to
go you know hey let's just get inspired
by actual 3d modeling tools and so yeah
you are essentially able to I mean the
plan was originally that we would put
like a certain number maybe ten or
something pre-built halls and the game
like in the earlier part of the demo you
saw that was like a preset hole right
and then everybody would have one of
these ten and you could progress and
unlock better ones etc etc then you know
our community really came out and said
we really want to be able to shape
create our own shapes I want to create
like a ball you know I want to create
like this really long skinny ship and I
want to create this crazy shape with
blah blah and we thought well we should
probably think about whether we can
bring this in earlier and and we did in
so now what we're doing it really
so now we want you to be able to yeah
great and now just like that you know
quite just playing some stuff you can
craft the whole itself and then of your
choice you earlier apply as well put the
helm down you put course goes you pan
way up and stuff but you have your basic
shape and then later on in this tool
will have where you can divide up into
corridors rooms and stuff like that so
did you guys art you have this be sort
of the way to make ships it's more or
you're still going to put in that or no
no this is that one the this will be
this will be the default way of creating
ships in the game we won't have any
really pre-built ships
there'll be some designs that are
already set up for you so if you don't
want to mess with the 3d kind of flavors
edit like a shaker oh yeah right let's
have a scratch scratch yeah exactly
visit this a quest small little one and
if we go down this this valley here
outside of the shipyard you'll see as
well there's update like shipyard
visuals and the other things you said
this is a slightly later on build but
just to give you an idea of some of the
ships you can make now again because
here we are in our further dishes
looking pretty monochrome we don't have
the ship parts with sort of like
completely final heart because he here
we feel like a much smaller with a skiff
type thing
and the ability now with the ship
shaping which you can sort of create
your own cockpits around the back here
I've been smart put the fuel tanks by
the helm you know just for complete
safety so you see I've set the the
artificial horizon just in front of me
there yeah and I've got the fuel off to
the left so but have it immediately in
my Myatt for city but it's just yeah you
can just pick up a ship and just start
flying it just like that that's the kind
of the seamless game we kind of wanted
it's just like a small nimble ship from
yeah pretty simple to build over here
we've got a much much bigger sort
classic flying ship that's almost like a
galleon with wings the material
so this is just like boo entirely a vine
to be honest well it's probably actually
get on it Luke couldn't be bothered to
harvest all the iron say yeah I just
cheated all any you can see I've started
to kind of build little sorghum sections
for our light stuff in here and I get
like these crates and light is all
entirely placeholder but it gives you an
idea if you know that's sort of the
freedom you have to just do whatever you
want and again you know you can just
jump on there's not really any sense of
ship ownership in the game
your kind is pretty freeform
mechanically you can just take on a ship
and you know start to fly down a
mountain valley you know you could have
20 friends on here just the two but
obviously if you're managing a ship of
this size probably requires fair amount
of people yeah if you imagine being in
combat I'm adding all these cannons and
stuff that sort of lining the deck I
imagine it does take a lot of resources
there
yes actually you're going to need a lot
of people who get a craft anytime take
some damage I have to repair it you need
the resources to repair but this thing
like trying to go through that storm
earlier it works or breathe through
because it you know yes it'd be getting
struck by lightning this so heavy that
the wind I wouldn't move it so much and
here we've got like sword more like a
hot rod spaceship thing already sure was
going on here but you know I was just
kind of playing around with different
shapes and sort of going a bit maybe
this week and this is more unusual are
you not limited like when it comes to
making the initial frame
no you can guess here we don't require
there's a source there's a limit to the
side they'll be a limit to the size
initiative probably like increase but we
definitely don't want to be like you can
build like a tiny dinghy initially I
think we want to give them a little bit
wiggle room to create you know something
you know something you find pretty cool
and later on as you get that technology
to you to start building just huge sort
of like Zeppelin sized things you'll be
able to find better schematics to
improve your shipyard to be able to
build bigger ships right and that's
that's one other track of progressions
we're trying to get out of the one Moss
this is this brings up a good point like
this is the kind of thing that you know
again the community brought up right and
internally we were sure if we want to do
it or there rather than later and
community really made us realize that we
should do this earlier that's kind of
one of those things where no this is a
now the generation of players that's
growing up with Minecraft and Kerbal
space program and all these things
they're they're not really satisfied
with the traditional way of doing things
in mmo's particularly online games which
have been you know somewhat stale right
that they follow a very formulaic very
successful very fun but also in some
ways very formulaic you know way of
doing things and you can't imagine that
kind of kid who's grown up playing
Kerbal space program to be okay with are
just like you're set this and you slot
in or whatever few things but this is
the ship that you have they want to be
able to make their own thing they want
to add have some shapes and you know
make it sleek and do whatever and
express themselves through their designs
so that's kind of the direction for the
dress really I know so the decision is
this is your base like in all of these
kind of games you you kind of build your
base up and they know it kind of almost
gets rid of the exploration aspect
because you only want to go so far away
from where you put all the time and
but where does feel like well what if
you the thing you're building the thing
the house do we all like these all
season the things that you've gathered
could move could fly and then suddenly
you take these huge structures basically
with you and and they are at your power
station they would even have to defend
yourself with come across other players
getting these huge skirmishes these huge
ship fights essentially I mean for me
the the the draw the initial draw for
the idea of the game was always like I
really want to I like the collaborative
aspect of building something about
friends and building castle doing other
stuff right a lot of games have that but
again like Luke said you can't take that
with you it's it's stationary so you got
to go further further to gather
resources or find things and it's kind
of like you know there's something it
doesn't quite work about that whereas
this is like we're building a thing
together it's our base we can literally
every part of it we built ourselves
right from the frame to the panels the
protection stuff to the engines to the
fuel tanks and even down to the
instruments we literally place the
instruments individually wherever we
want so that when you're flying it you
can you build your own UI essentially
right in world UI and and then you can
improve it you can swap out parts like
oh I found some titanium I want to
replace that copper crappy copper thing
right so you land you dock your ship you
make some improvements swaps them out
things out and then carry on and then
once you go through a storm you take a
bunch of damage but then you make it out
from the other side and then you you
know doc make some repairs make some
improvements you're like you know what
we should have done that we shouldn't
put this here this is too close to that
whatever it is right and then you make
the improvements you learn how to make
your ship better and maybe you know if
you lose your ship you like all right
let's start over I got a way better idea
for design instead of a long skinny ship
let's do a big whatever ship you know
that's the kind of that's the gameplay
that really excites me all right and I
hope a lot of our players agree right
it's incredibly collaborative yeah for
sure come yeah yeah I know I guess like
that's all that create freedom of
expression is is what we've extended
through to like the islands so we have a
the on crater which is free on Steam and
every island you've actually seen has
been playing
today has all been entirely
player-created so it's like even at this
early stage like we're now for running
out for tests are regularly and then
yeah that is like even now we've got the
players who actually physically building
our world which is also really exciting
for us it means that you picked up
Scylla well no just the distance on the
horizon travel there and you know we're
going to find there but it's been
thought about by somebody it's not just
procedurally generated yeah right this
is a combination in the final game will
be a combination see right and of course
there will be some ones that we offer
ourselves but the fact that right now
yeah like yeah we can't take any credit
for these islands they're beautiful
they're amazing a lot of these designs
we never would have made ourselves right
you know you kind of open up to the
community and you see all the crazy
things they can come up with all the
beautiful amazing designs that they come
up with and you know we see that with
all kinds of parts of the game with the
ships I imagine we'll see some
ridiculous designs oh yeah oh yes the
data that wraps up like a very I mean
it's a lot to talk about it I lived a
lot and hopefully as as we kind of get
that out into players and they can start
making more informal dota videos than we
ever can okay yeah but uh thanks for
watching
you